he is now favorite to succeed David
Cameron so George Osborne's trade
visitor China this week has been even
more closely watched than normal
was it all about seeming prime
ministerial well we sat down with the
Chancellor to find out and started by
asking whether he challenged Beijing on
their human rights record but we raise
human rights issues and I've raised them
on this specifically what kind of i-i've
specifically specific human rights
issues on this visit so whether that did
but in the end it's it's a relationship
with China where it's not conducted
through television interviews and
megaphone diplomacy
you know I've honestly probably concern
back in the UK and that's what you know
I think what people realize is vital as
human rights are it is one part of our
relationship with a country that
represents one fifth of the world's
population we need China for our economy
if you're concerned about climate change
you need to engage with China you came
you came very channeled here just after
University didn't you so what was it
that drew you here back then before you
know you're a politician that'll a
Chancellor well look China is an
incredible part of our our world it's a
fifth of the world's population
it's an ancient civilization it's
contributed hugely to the way the world
thinks about itself to our philosophy
and our literature our understanding of
science but it's also a huge part of the
world's future and you know I came to
this city when I was in my early 20s it
was nothing like the size it is today
they didn't have train stations right
and use a backpack where all that came
with my backpack and stayed in the
student hostel and and it's it's good to
have seen China you know
like that as well because it gives me an
appreciation actually what they've
achieved it's a big delegation we've
been to lots of places and being
welcomed very grandly there are also
people traveling some people say it
feels quite prime ministerial but I say
it's the job of the chance Exchequer to
come to China to connect our economy
China is a vital part of my economic
plan does it ever take you when people
keep raising this well look in this just
interested it's probably it's it's
flattery rather than anything you know
the most important thing in this job is
to try and keep an even temperament you
know I was being told just a few months
ago before the general election by
people are reading the opinion polls and
I was gonna be out of a job and these
alone in the middle of May well I know
is that you know I'm paid to focus on
the economic problems the country has
faced to address those problems to turn
this country around with the help of the
British people that's what I'm 100%
focused on final anecdote from me which
I just would love your reaction to when
we're getting off the flight a Chinese
family in front we're pointing out of
the window and I have one of them in
Chinese say to the other motto how do
you speak Mandarin oh no no in Chinese
this is the one so they're checking
because you said you heard I will tell
you the two words I understood winners
David Cameron oh that's because he was
actually here in cha well maybe it made
us a couple of years ago maybe chancer
but maybe they thought this was both
prime ministerial visit I don't know
it's a it's a partnership and we choose
the boss